many people have healthcare workers in
the family who are helping fight the
corona virus but we found one family
where one two three four sisters all
four of them are nurses right there on
the front lines
there's Kimberly and Ashley they work in
the same Virginia Hospital then there's
Gina she works in a Maryland emergency
room and last but not least there's
Courtney she works in an ICU that's when
in California our national correspondent
Jericka Duncan spoke to all of them
about why they wanted to become nurses
in the first place it's so much fun to
share that with all my sisters friends
still call them the Carol girls they
span an age from 46 to 29 and live in
different parts of the country their
father served in the US Army and their
mother works in a high school while
these sisters may have different last
names now they're united in their
commitment to others how much do you
think your background and you all being
sisters and all going into the same
field play and how you care for others
I'm 105 nurses five girls and I treat my
patients like I would if it were my
parents in that bed or if it were my
sisters I think looking into your
patients eyes and trying to convey a
level of safety is the most important
thing that we can do because it was
conveyed to us with the loss of our
sister in a very sudden way in 2008
their sister Tina
Gina's identical twin passed away
suddenly from a heart condition she was
also a pediatric nurse and I saw my
older sisters and how strong they were
for all of us associated at all with
being a nurse you know I thought it was
our superpower people they compared it
to like superheroes now in the pandemic
but it's something I've always felt in
our in our little Carol girl family is
we've got we can take on anything do you
feel even more value today than you ever
have in your careers people are
regarding us in the same light as as
military war heroes and there's times
where I step back and like wait it's not
like that but then I go but I guess we
are fighting
or early on in this pandemic I'm sure
you saw the videos of nurses breaking
down doctors breaking down was there
ever a moment where you felt or
questioned should I be doing this right
now
if someone says they're not scared
they're lying cuz you're scared but you
never doubt not doing your job what
advice do you have for those nurses out
there the biggest advice I have for
people is to talk we are so used to
taking care of people that we bottle
everything up if my family has taught me
anything it is in times of crisis you
have to get things out and once you do
that it almost transforms you into a
different person you're able to care for
yourself your family and other people
that was tareka Duncan reporting the
last time that the Carroll sisters were
all physically together was last
Christmas but guess what they plan to
reunite in August as they do every year
on the anniversary of their sister
Tina's death even if that means wearing
a mask and gloves in keeping their
distance
I do think Anthony they've got great
superpowers and I can think only think
about Tina how proud she must be
watching all her sisters carry on what a
great story jurika